I'm asking you to notice that the very
same blue team which I am saying is for
some reason degrading our military
Readiness while it is a pay-per-play
system with few if any safeguards
against who buys access that that same
thing is also taking actions that are
completely inexplicable with respect to
school children well actually I mean it
look again I I don't know enough to talk
about this stuff but if you're asking
why are uh vaccine you know if I were to
be asked to accept your premises like
the vaccines they don't do much of any
good maybe they do net harm why they be
so widely uh administered I would resort
to the big Pharma explanation okay but
that's a different question
that would be my go-to conspiracy
hypothesis but that's a different
question I thought we were here to
discuss what you claimed on this podcast
which I think is an irresponsible thing
to claim in an era I mean ask Nancy
Pelosi's husband how how careful we
should be maybe before declaring people
enemies of the state that's the
environment we're in and what you said
certainly would give people the
impression you're suggesting that people
in in the Democratic Administration or
enemies estate now you're telling us
it's different I don't buy I don't buy
the the what you're saying now doesn't
make sense to me either but please let
me get to my next two hypotheses
please I I don't understand what
conversation we're having I mean you you
specifically say look I don't know
enough to assess this I'm saying look
it's transparent on its face that we are
making an error as large as
administering a dangerous highly novel
treatment to children who don't need it
and won't benefit from it and for no
reason it would still not be justified
if it if it did block transmission
because it's not it's not reasonable to
harm children to save vulnerable old
people but even that explanation has
fallen by the wayside I know that's just
you Robert this is since my podcast
we are still doing this the policy
Marches On completely divorced from
reality
right right I know I know that's your
view but I didn't tweet about that part
of your view I tweeted about your claim
that someone is intentionally
undermining military Readiness via the
military vaccine policy can we get back
to that or do you just not want to
discuss it
cute
um it's not that I don't want to discuss
it it's that I do not want you framing
it in isolation as if we don't have
multiple extremely difficult to explain
things happening across many different
domains simultaneously because the point
is you can say that my hypothesis is
irresponsible and maybe even crazy if
you can isolate it but in context the
fact is we are dealing with something
that has caused our system to go
completely insane and it is not only
going insane but it is targeting
children right you have to look for an
explanation big enough to deal with that
is Pharma corruption big enough maybe
maybe I accept that as a possible
hypothesis but it is hard to understand
why a civilian Authority that can
recognize that these mandates needed to
be lifted for the public still maintains
them for the military
what is that what happened
let me just repeat that for the purposes
of the argument I'm making what you just
said
doesn't matter okay I know you believe
that for the purposes of the argument
I'm making it doesn't matter let me be
let me finish whether what you just said
is true it Ma it does matter to some
extent whether what you just said is if
you widely shared like in the Pentagon
and in the administration I'm here to
tell you it's not okay and and I just I
hope there's some logicians out there
who understand the argument I'm making
and understand that it doesn't rise or
fall on whether Brett Weinstein's view
of covet is right it rises or Falls
parts of some of the hypotheses rise or
fall on the question of whether Brett
Weinstein's view is the view that
prevails in America and you know damn
well it doesn't that's what's you know
you talk about that all the time
false that is logically false because
because the hypothesis I Advanced is
that you have a pay for play system in
which people aren't paying close
attention to what is or isn't good for
military Readiness or children or the
transmission of the disease because they
have of higher priorities that's
actually the hypothesis you advances is
some of these people are paying
attention to military Readiness and want
to degrade it no that's different no you
absolutely did
no because as you read it you even
noticed as you were reading that quote
you said you in that case was a foreign
entity that might have wished to
accomplish these things acting through
the blue team right okay are you saying
somebody wants to enter my military
Readiness well look our military enemies
certainly want to undermine our military
but the point is but the point is you're
even positing uh that the administ
people Administration must be
indifferent to like good and bad
consequences depends on their accepting
your view of covet and vaccines and so
on and they don't they don't influence
Peddlers they're indifferent to our
well-being that's why they're selling us
out
uh
you know it it it's possible that they
are but oh my God the assertion the
assertion that the vaccine policy
unambiguously indicates that they are
very Ambiguously I said hypothesis
now let me let me let me let me read you
a quote from yours
whatever it is you're talking about this
entity out there this is what you said
whatever it is is at the very least
completely indifferent to our readiness
it doesn't care if we're at our best or
maybe it wants us unready then you also
said the absolute least pernicious
explanation is total indifference to the
well-being of service members and the
Readiness of our military force so
you're saying there is zero probability
that the people responsible for this
past this policy are not indifferent to
the well-being of service members and
Readiness you're saying there's zero
chance that's the logical meaning of
those two statements do you agree
you are playing a shell game because I
do believe that whatever engineered the
policy has to be at least completely
indifferent that does not mean that the
people who made the policy happen are
indifferent
I do believe they are de facto
indifferent because they are corrupt
they are allowing themselves to be
steered by things that have something
other than the public Public's
well-being at their core that is what
they're doing they're doing that for
money or power or both I don't know but
they're de facto indifferent not not du
jour
I'm saying
I I never mind I I mean I I think
it's clear in your your podcast that
you're saying it must be the case they
just don't care about the well-being of
service members you said policy must be
indifferent okay that's your claim
there's no chance
that it could be anything else
whereas whereas I just it you know and
what you just said is whoever designed
the policy well come on it's very easy
to explain now you're playing
philosophical games okay if I say
that we exist and are having a
conversation am I saying there is no
chance that one of us is a brain in a
jar being fed information to see what we
will do
no uh I'm not going to technically rule
that out but yes for the from the point
of view of what plausibly explains the
conversation that we are having you and
I are two human beings with a
disagreement interacting over the
Internet okay okay so I am saying the
same thing here is it you know is it
possible you know uh who knows am I a
schizophrenic who uh you know imagined
that there was something called covid
and that this is all happening in my
head I guess but I'm not going to spend
a whole lot of time worrying about that
what I think I've got is a lot of
information about how this system is
behaving none of it makes a wit of sense
it does appear to be rather completely I
mean again you you decide that you get
the right to rule out the question of
well okay we've got two completely
irrational seemingly indifferent
policies in two different Realms right
you don't want to talk about why even
though I'm sure you have enough
information to know it makes no sense to
administer mRNA vaccines to children for
covet right literally haven't looked at
the data I'm sorry I don't have young
children I'm a horrible person for not
being conversant in it I'm sorry I
looked my intuition is
what I'm telling you is you're living in
a phase of history in which we are
actually
contemplating mandating
of radical therapies that do not benefit
the individuals in question without
giving informed consent to them or in
this case their parents right we are
actually contemplating doing this
even though we know that the risks from
these things go heavily to the young for
multiple reasons that both because
they're more dangerous to the young and
because the young have longer lives
ahead of them and that the benefits go
in the opposite direction if there's any
benefit at all to these treatments they
do not go to young people and yet we're
doing it so my my point to you is
probably a couple hours work on your
part would reveal to you that we have
some crazy policy in motion that cannot
be explained epidemiologically or
medically or logically or any other way
that that policy is actually happening
that it's not something that happened
and has been slow to be reversed this is
more recent than the podcast you were
complaining about this is taking place
now you the problem is
the level of dysfunction exceeds normal
explanations and what I see you doing is
wanting to narrow down the question to
exactly one dysfunctional thing and then
stretch the hypotheses that you consider
reasonable to the extent that they can
cover that one thing and my point is
well that's not the context they exist
in you're existing in a moment where we
have somebody who's president who is
exhibiting Extreme cognitive decline
which means you and I don't know what's
President it means we've effectively
elected a party at best
that party is corrupt so we don't really
know what we've ushered into the
executive branch and we have all of
these policies that are emerging that
make no sense at all and do appear to
emerge from complete indifference to the
well-being of Americans
[Music]